and we're going back to a position now
where university dorms are being
racially segregated
where people are only shopping at
businesses that
share their their racial tribal
affiliations there's a woman
who was very upset because she went into
a boba tea place boba tea you know boba
tea
it's that tea that has those weird
little balls in it and you kind of it's
kind of nice
anyway it's an it's an asian beverage a
woman walks into this store
which is run by asians and she's very
upset because the boba tea
place is not a black owned business take
a listen
this establishment is uh not black owned
by using you're stealing black culture
is this not black culture trap tea the
boba plug
no your thief asian people stealing
black
black culture once again once again it's
okay you'll be exposed though
you're not black owned you're still
least my future
thank you no i came here because i
thought it was black owned
that's why i came here i told my friends
i'm supporting a black business
this is not black owned you're not this
is not black owned
asian stealing stealing black culture
once again
okay so it goes on from there i think
you get the idea she's arguing at the
end with this black guy who says hey
lady you're you're in an asian joint
why are you screaming about oh it's not
a black-owned business
and then she calls him a racial slur
because he doesn't have his tribal
solidarity which the democrats are
trying to gin up because they think it's
the only way they can win the election
i think i'm going to walk into general
sao's chinese chicken palace
and demand that it be become a
sicilian-owned business
why is this chinese joint not sicilian
owned i only eat it sicilian-owned
businesses i probably wouldn't be able
to eat at very many places
if i only went to sicilian-owned
businesses right but one of the nice
things about america is we don't have to
check someone's racial pedigree
before we go in and buy a sandwich or a
cup of iced tea
but that's the point that the left wants
us to get to by the way what does it
mean to be a black owned business
because it's not just this kooky lady
who goes into the shop this is not some
fringe thing ubereats
was giving special privileges to black
owned businesses
you didn't have to pay a delivery fee if
you
aided a black-owned business they were
actually giving out privileges based on
race
well you know what if your business
say has gives equity to five people and
someone who owns one percent of the
business
is black and then the people on the
other 99
of the business are like the whitest
people in the world is that a black
owned business a black guy owns part of
it
how are we gonna do what if it's a what
if it's a guy who's half black
and half uh jewish i don't know
how how is that going to work how are we
going to plug that into the
the racial victimhood calculator and
figure out exactly how much of that
business
we should we should shop at doesn't make
a whole lot of sense
what it boils down to here at what this
woman's argument
is is that it's cultural appropriation
now i don't think that boba tea comes
from
from africa or from you know the pla the
american plantation before the civil war
or something like that
but she's calling it cultural
appropriation
even if the points you were making even
if the premise that boba tea is
is somehow black even if that were true
cultural appropriation is a very good
thing
in fact all culture has to be
appropriated
this is a big lie that the left doesn't
seem probably they don't understand
because they don't know what culture is
culture relates to the word cultivation
release the word cult for instance right
you cultivate something in yourself i
was not born loving beethoven
believe it or not even though you know i
don't think my mother ever played baby
beethoven for me now i think some like
bourgeois white mothers do this in the
cities they play beethoven to their
stomachs and they think
their kids are gonna become really smart
and sophisticated this way i did not
have that i was not born
listening to beethoven but i like
beethoven very much why
because i cultivated that taste i was
not born
smoking cigars i may as well have been
because i started at an early age
but i cultivated that taste i cultivated
my appreciation of certain art
cultivated my appreciation of certain
literature i was not born
reading italian is that cultural
appropriation i guess it is but it's
great because now i get to read dante
all cultures is appropriated it's by the
way the premise of of
immigration and assimilation in america
we have the most open we have a
ridiculously open immigration system in
america
which most people by the way want to
dramatically curtail across racial
groups
but part of the reason we have any
functioning immigration system at all
is based on assimilation that you have
to come in and appropriate the american
culture
and the american cult and you have to
give up some culture too when you do
that
what this woman is saying is no we're
gonna have a pedigree test we're gonna
check your blood
see exactly what percentage black you
are cultural appropriation is really
good who invented pasta
speaking of the italians was it the
italians we actually don't know was it
the italians was it the chinese was it
somewhere in the middle we don't know
we just like it it's good i'm glad now
everybody has pasta
it's cultivating oneself but
we're not allowed to have that we're
moving in the opposite direction we
have a completely degraded culture and
the culture is decaying
more and more by the day and we have at
the same time
coincidentally divvying up racial groups
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you